I say hijack hi jack everybody everyone
who needs to do that wait can I kill you
- well did you wanted me here so
[Music]
this world
you're just alike can you see them like
to try things ever
that's the fragrance so why don't you go
kill yourself again
[Music]
[Applause]
you can't stop me i blaze in fill and
when you come to Princeton your tea will
be cold and your crumpets will be burnt
trying to settle in the middle of
something we're sorry oh sorry Oh
I'm the only one did you forget about me
teachers
scram
[Music]
we beat mother [ __ ] its top star and
my gal can explode your berries behind
there it's Daniel
what you didn't get it the curly hair
the rebranding hi I didn't mean to
interrupt your calm serene mood to
remind you that your friends are talking
about you okay it's lovely pollution
with every hip thrust toxic smog gets
released into the air
you forgot about me Ian Hecox
[Music]
[Applause]
baby
[Music]